this is a story that the daily wire
broke i think we were the first ones to
this story just came out last night and
it's going to be completely suppressed
by the media it's already being
suppressed by the media so pay attention
louden county
which has had a lot of problems in its
schools a lot of people protesting in
loudoun county because the schools are
covering up the radical
racial politics that are being taught
the radical gender sexual politics
they're being taught well it goes
further than just the curriculum
on june 22 scott smith was arrested at
loudoun county at a school board meeting
and the meeting was ultimately deemed an
unlawful assembly because
scott smith
was a father in the district was
speaking out against a policy that lets
boys go into the women's bathroom and he
said and that's all you saw that's all
people saw of the stories this guy this
crazy right-wing dad gets arrested at
the school board meeting because he is
anti-trans he's a transphobe and this is
mean and awful and bigoted
well what's the story
the
father
was the father of this young girl this
15-year-old girl
who was raped
in a bathroom
at the school
by a boy
a boy who considers himself gender fluid
who sometimes wears a dress who went
into the school and allegedly raped the
girl
there is a lot of evidence for this the
daily wire investigative team did a very
good job parsing out this story
according to the father on may 28 a boy
wearing a skirt entered the girls
bathroom at stone bridge high school and
sexually assaulted smith's 9th grade
daughter and
i don't want to go into the details too
much on this show but i know that the
term sexual assault is very broad these
days some people say sexual assault even
refers to if you just kiss somebody or
something like that
what this
boy who sometimes pretends to be a girl
is accused of doing to this ninth grade
girl
is as bad as it gets
as vile as perverted as sick as violent
as it gets okay
and it's being covered up and the school
has denied it and then the evidence came
out that it actually happened and
they're still trying to deny they're
trying to portray the father is the bad
guy here beca why because they can't
admit that their policy is wrong
evil
false and puts the students in danger
and why because the experts have told us
that this can't happen gas prices are
insanely high right now i don't need to
tell you that i'm sure you've noticed it
well i'm thrilled to introduce to you an
incredible app that everyone who buys
gas needs to know about get upside
my listeners are making up to 25 cents
for every gallon of gas every time they
fill up just download the free get
upside app in the app store or google
play right now use promo code knowles
and get a bonus 25 cents per gallon on
your first fill up that's up to 50 cents
cash back do not pay full price at the
pump anymore get cash back using get
upside down load the app for free and
use promo code knowles canon wles to get
up to 50 cents per gallon cash back on
your first tank some people who drive a
lot are making as much as two to three
hundred dollars a month in cash back
there's no catch the cash back gets
added right to your account you can cash
out any time to your bank account paypal
or an e-gift card for amazon and other
brands just download the free get upside
app and use promo code nolskw-les to get
up to 50 cents per gallon cashback on
your first tank that's code knowles if
you let boys and grown men i guess even
go into the girls bathroom nothing bad
will happen look these boys they're just
they actually they're girls secretly
sometimes they're not even girls all the
time they're just if they're fluid
they're just girls sometimes when they
feel like it and it's very wrong and
closed-minded of you to keep boys out of
the girl's room why of course the girl's
room is for boys that's why it's called
the girls room if the girls if the boys
say that their girl's right that's what
the experts say
they say this can't happen the experts
furthermore say that this dad is a
domestic terrorist if you go in to a
school board and you question the racial
and gender radicalism going on at the
school boards well according to our
attorney general that makes you a
domestic terrorist
and yet
what does the investigation show
this dad is the most sane person in the
room you are the most sane person in the
room you assuming that you listening to
this
story right now are the sort of person
who thinks that actually boys should not
go into the girls bathroom that actually
boys cannot just become girls and
there's something a little wrong about
that
you are far from a domestic terrorist
you are the last sane person
one of the last same people in this
culture and the experts are wrong and
the prevailing ideology is wrong and
common sense and prudence are right and
the ruling class wants to shut that up
and censor that and deny that and punish
people who think that as best they can
[Music]
[Music]